en este vídeo tenemos esta cantidad de
globos y la manera más sencilla en la
que podemos contarlos es bueno de uno en
uno no la más la más obvia no la más
sencilla la más obvia 1 2 3 larga sin
embargo tenemos muchos globos y en este
caso cuando se nos incremente la
cantidad de objetos a contar podemos
hacer lo siguiente y será mucho más
sencillo dado que tenemos esto arreglado
de una manera como muy linda en donde
tenemos columnas y filas podemos hacer
la multiplicación como vamos a usar la
multiplicación para esto pues muy
sencillo lo primero que vamos a hacer es
contar las columnas así es que tenemos 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 columnas lo ven y ahora
también contaremos cuantas filas tenemos
las filas los vamos a contar de la
siguiente manera de las filas van de
forma horizontal
una dos tres cuatro filas así es que
ahora sabemos que tenemos siete columnas
y cuatro filas vamos a escribir eso
tenemos cuatro filas
las
y también tenemos siete columnas 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 7 columnas
cómo es que utilizaremos esta
información cuatro filas y siete
columnas para saber el total que tenemos
de globos pues multiplicaremos las
cuatro filas por
las siete columnas por siete cuatro
filas por siete o también podemos
multiplicar las siete columnas por las
cuatro filas
simplemente estoy cambiando el orden sin
embargo la información es la misma tengo
cuatro filas por siete columnas o siete
columnas por cuatro filas como sé que
esto me va a funcionar realmente para
tener los datos completos pues muy
sencillo si yo estoy considerando cuatro
filas entonces estaremos hablando de
éstas
y se dan cuenta tenemos siete objetos
tengo cuatro grupos
donde cada uno de estos grupos tiene
siete objetos en este caso los globos
rojos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 tengo cuatro de
estos conjuntos
que cada uno tienen siete objetos o de
la misma manera si pensamos a niveles de
columna tendremos siete grupos
y cada uno de estos grupos tendrá cuatro
objetos no ven tengo siete grupos y cada
uno tiene cuatro objetos es por eso que
nos va a funcionar nuestra
multiplicación así es que vamos a hacer
lo siguiente si nosotros tenemos cuatro
por siete hoy deberíamos de sabernos
nuestras tablas o poco a poco lo
tendremos sin embargo podemos hacerlo
como la suma se acuerdan cuatro
sumándose a sí mismo siete veces vamos a
hacer simplemente el conteo hacia arriba
sumando de cuatro en cuatro para llegar
al resultado primero tendríamos cuatro
8 12 16
20 24 28 estoy haciendo un incremento de
4 en 4 vemos si tenemos ya sería 4 por 1
4 por 2 por tres por 4 por 5 por 6 por 7
veces
entonces esto nos dará nuestro resultado
en el que 4 por 7 es igual a 28
vamos bien será lo mismo con el 7
debería de serlo vamos a revisarlo vamos
a volver a hacer la suma de 7 en 7 a ver
si 7 sumándose a sí mismo 4 a veces nos
da 28 el primer 7 bueno
si a 7 le sumó 7 tendré 14 7 21 728 y
justo está en 7 por 17 por 2 7 por 3 7
por 4 tenemos la misma respuesta 7 por 4
será igual a 20 8
y entonces esto se ve muy sencillo de
esta manera podemos tener nuestro
resultado les voy a mostrar con esta
misma cantidad de globos otra forma en
la que podemos hacerlo y esto está
también muy sencillo también tal vez
todavía no te sabes perfectamente las
tablas de 4 x 7 o 7 x 4 sin embargo
podemos hacer esto de alguna manera más
sencilla a mí me funciona y se los
quiero compartir voy a mover este
letrero
aquí colocaré de nuevo las operaciones
tengo 4
por este 7 lo puedo dividir de tal
manera que yo sé que 7 es igual a 5 + 2
y el 5 me resulta más fácil y el 2
también entonces lo que voy a hacer es
primero separar mi gran bloque de 7
columnas en una de 5
aquí tengo 5 columnas
y tendré otra segunda columna de 2
se dan cuenta de esta forma tengo que 4
por 7 es igual a 4 por 5 2 vamos a
colorear la parte para que se vea el
bloque completo
yo tendré entonces este primer bloque de
5 columnas
y cinco con otro bloque de dos que
colocar en anaranjado
tal vez así está más sencillo de ver
esto indicaría que la suma de este
primer bloque de cuatro filas por cinco
columnas más el total de cuatro filas
por dos columnas me dará exactamente el
mismo resultado será aquí vamos a
aplicar una propiedad que se llama
propiedad distributiva se los voy a
explicar en uno más adelante pero es
importante que vayan sabiendo el nombre
donde el cuatro por cinco más dos
también lo podemos considerar como 4 por
y esa será nuestra primer multiplicación
que se le sumará
4 x
con anaranjado para mantener el mismo
color y voy a poner los paréntesis
porque ustedes ya saben cuál es el orden
de las operaciones cuando tenemos
multiplicaciones divisiones o sumas y
restas dentro de la misma operación
primero haremos las multiplicaciones con
esto va a ser mucho más sencillo y este
es el orden de las operaciones
así es que tendremos 4 por 5 que
finalmente ya es muchísimo más sencillo
para mí saber que 4 por 5 es igual a 20
le suma el resultado de 4 por 24 por 12
las tablas de multiplicar que llámese es
igual a 8 de tal manera tenemos la suma
de 20 más 8 es igual a 20 8 lo ven y
tenemos exactamente el mismo resultado
que hemos tenido arriba por lo que si es
congruente donde por lo que si es
congruente
tal vez me es más complicado saber 4 por
7 pero sé que si los separó en dos
grandes bloques es más sencillo saber
que 4 por 5 es igual a 20 y 4 por 2 es
igual a 8 lo sumo y con eso tengo mi
respuesta correcta les voy a poner otro
ejemplo y entenderán en este espacio
cómo es que resulta mucho más sencillo
cuando son operaciones más grandes voy a
hacer espacio
aquí ya tenemos más espacio les decía
que esto es para operaciones mucho más
grandes qué pasa si ahora tengo por
ejemplo una nueva operación que me dice
cuánto es 6
por un número grande vamos a poner un
número grande en 36 y este número ahora
es más complicado sin embargo tengo la
posibilidad de hacer la separación como
lo hicimos con la propiedad distributiva
se acuerdan este mismo 6 por 36 yo lo
puedo representar como 6 x de qué manera
les gustaría separar este 36 yo pensaría
en 30
+ 6 porque finalmente 36 es igual a 36
vamos a colocar aquí más 6
pongo muchos colores para que sea más
sencillo la codificación de estos y sea
más claro nuestro ejemplo ok
si yo tengo 6 x 36 lo que voy a hacer es
distribuir este 6
en ambos números
por lo que ahora tendré
por 30
son muchos colores 6 x 30
que esto será sumado a la multiplicación
de
por 6 y es mucho más sencillo bueno para
mí es mucho más sencillo como ven
ustedes es mucho más sencillo saber que
6 por 30 lo puedo hacer y 6 por 6
también 6 por 3 es igual a 18
así es que 6 por 30 será igual a 180
vamos bien y a eso le suma el producto
de la multiplicación 6 por 6 6 por 6
está muy fácil son 36
ahora puedo hacer mis 180 36 será igual
a 180 más 36 bueno hacemos nuestra suma
de columna por columna 06 es igual a 68
3 es igual a 11 y llevo una uno más uno
es igual a dos por lo tanto nuestro
resultado final será 216 recuerda esta
es la propiedad distributiva donde
estamos distribuyendo el número que está
multiplicando ante los dos que se están
sumando 6 por 30 más 6 es igual a 6 por
30 primer multiplicación a la que le
sumaremos
6 x 6 que aquí lo tenemos y de esta
manera llegamos a nuestro resultado
final es importante que se aprendan esto
ya que poco a poco les va a dar muchas
más bases para poder resolver
operaciones de multiplicación mucho más
compleja espero haber sido clara y nos
vemos en otro vídeo